madame monsieur bonsoir dans ce journal
nous allons bien sûr revenir sur le sort
des otages français du liban avec
notamment le retour en france du docteur
rade l'un des émissaires français mais
d'abord la superbe victoire du quinze
tricolore cet après midi au parc des
princes face à l'angleterre
29 à 10 et un score sans appel qui
votent aux rugbymen français de
remporter le tournoi des cinq nations
ex-aequo avec les causes qui a de son
côté battu l'irlande à dublin
on attendait le pack anglais se furent
bien souvent les avants français qui
firent la différence tout de suite les
moments forts de ce match avec lionel
chamoulaud le masque du capitaine daniel
dubroca et de ses avants juste avant le
match
le tournoi se gagne aujourd'hui une demi
heure de jeu la france mène 6 0 2
pénalités de la porte
à part cela rien d'autre à signaler les
anglais pour une fois dans les 22 mètres
français vont se faire prendre en contre
charvet intercepte bonneval pour la
porte la porte c'est encore une fois
charvet qui lui remet et guy laporte à
33 ans laisse tout le monde sur place
au bout de 40 mètres de sprint 10 à 0 le
match est lancé
début de deuxième mi temps les bleus
dominent à cinq mètres de l'en but
anglais la troisième ligne garde le
ballon progression dame elle est
française épervier catapulte blanco a
laissé 14 à 0 le rugby d'attac commence
à payer
les anglais réduisent enfin le score
avec cette pénalité de barnes 17 à 3 et
sur la remise en jeu la porte place le
ballon mais c'est serge blanco qui
frappe directement pour jean baptiste
lafond la faune pour celles à celle à
qui prend le couloir et regardez bien à
l'interception de barnes moment de
flottement dans le stade car l'art dit
monsieur bevan accorde un essai de
pénalité alors pierre albaladejo
explications
regardez le déborde lors de celle à qui
à l'intérieur va vouloir passer la balle
à charvet et regardez ici hop vous avez
vu avec la mer le défenseur anglais qui
au lieu de plaquer le porteur du ballon
ou de se saisir de celui ci a fait une
interception qui équivalait à une
pénalité
en tout cas cela fait 23 à 3 les blancs
sur cette couche inscrit un essai par le
géant doux les 23 à cette première
essais concédés par les français en deux
tournois
dommage mais dans le regard de gardiens
on comprend que la fête ne peut pas se
terminer ainsi
mêlée à l'avantagé des bleus et
berbizier lance la cavalerie erik
bonneval plein champ au culot et avec
une super accélération les quatre
anglais sur place la différence s'est
faite bonneval cr charvet charvet pour
cela' et philippe sella file entre les
poteaux 29 à 10
philippe sella a un style un essai par
match dans ce tournoi il a réussi son
grand chelem
l'équipe de france elle l'a raté deux
plombs mais remporte de plus de 20
noeuds tournoi 1986 albaladejo ça c'est
l'équipe de france qu'on aime voir sur
le terrain
oui absolument et c'est un jeu très très
complet avec du physique c'est vrai mais
aussi de l'art qui s'exprime par les
trois quarts qui sont des joueurs
absolument merveilleux époustouflant des
moments de grâce comme le dernier risque
qu'on a vu oui ces dernières et c est
parti de très loin et qui confirme tout
le bien que nous pensions de cette
équipe de france qui a été en pente
ascendante depuis le début du match
depuis le début du tournoi on peut
regretter la défaite des causes parce
que nous avions une équipe à faire le
grand chelem
malheureusement bon le sort n'a pas
voulu que ce soit ici mais c'est
peut-être reculer pour mieux sauter pour
revenir à la france on avait dit
attention paquet d'avants anglais en
fait les français ont tourné très vite
dès la première minute le pack wii c'est
ça oui il y avait un défi que les
anglais nous avait lancé par presse
interposée d'izard de toute façon avec
le pas que nous avons nous allons faire
reculer les français à partir de là les
français ne pourront rien bâtir et puis
la grosse surprise est effectivement
cette première mêlée dont vous parlez et
quelle ne fut pas surprise de des
spectateurs et même peut-être d